la tragedia de la escuela primaria Duval
de cumple un año el 24 de mayo de 2022
un tirador de 18 años irrumpió en la
primaria rock y protagonizó un ataque
que duró 77 minutos
19 niños y dos maestros murieron las
heridas siguen frescas para la comunidad
de esta localidad de Texas como es el
caso de Verónica mata madre de tés una
de las niñas asesinadas
tenemos que aprender a revivir nuestras
vidas
porque nuestras vidas no son las mismas
y nuestras vidas nunca serán las mismas
Entonces siempre falta esa pieza
Sabes quiero decir
realmente no hay nada que pueda detener
lo que estoy sintiendo A menos que
puedan traerla de vuelta pero no pueden
hacer eso
en paralelo continúan las
investigaciones sobre el crimen y la
deficiencia respuesta de la policía que
demoraron intervenir y luego dio
versiones contradictorias para
justificar su accionar
esta semana es una semana difícil ni
siquiera podemos imaginar el dolor que
las familias están sintiendo un año y
nos damos cuenta de que todavía no
tienen las respuestas que necesitan y
eso nos ha frustrado a todos pido
disculpas el gobierno de Estados Unidos
incita en la necesidad de leyes que
restrinjan la posesión de armas mientras
eso parece un objetivo lejano las armas
de fuego son la principal causa de
muerte de niños y adolescentes solo en
2022 se registraron más de 300
incidentes en instituciones educativas
causando al menos 270 muertes mientras
en 2023 ya hubo por lo menos 33 hechos
de esta clase